[Music]
I have more than comfortable putting
loads of meat in my mouth
I was excited he's more of a hovering
than soaring gracefully but it'll do
yay I love finding severed body parts
[Applause]
you've been the best friend I could ask
for I love you love you too ro a theory
about a show I'm in where I play myself
but also a detective from the 1970s that
would be meta enough but get this the
show escape tonight actually sponsored
this video and approved me talking about
how the show's host is actually evil and
can't be trusted the level of meta in
this episode has just hit a brand new
extreme
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory a true YouTube
original not like an official show
produced by YouTube YouTube original I
just mean an original series only found
here on YouTube you know what is a show
produced by YouTube who ever escaped the
night the longest-running YouTube
original series of all time which
ironically enough also has the longest
tagline for a show of all time according
to the show's trailer escape tonight is
a postmodern unscripted murder mystery
sir reality-competition things like a
mad lib on steroids
yes YouTube I too can throw adjectives
into a blender and make them appear on
screen and fancy graphics film theory is
YouTube's coolest most complex Gore
filled educational animated pop-culture
info graphic analysis slideshow slap
that on a t-shirt and sell it but for as
much as I joke escape tonight is at its
core something all us theorists love a
mystery a super-sized horror themed
escape room where every step along the
way a popular youtuber dies you know the
show is almost like a youtuber rite of
passage at this point but some of the
biggest creators on the platform showing
up to prove their puzzle-solving prowess
season one had the likes of glozell Lele
pons and Shane Dawson season two
featured tanomo Joel Isaac Hoshi and
Gabby Hannah and season three it's a
best season cuz it's my season had a ton
of my favorite people both on and off
youtube like colleen ballinger Sofia
Nygaard and my sister from another
mister Rosanna pansino and now season
four the newest season which launches
today promises to feature the best of
the best as it's an all-star season I
mean how you doing all-star season when
canonically everyone is dead is beyond
me but then again I was dead too at one
point and I got revived so setting the
trends hashtag dead and loving it but
here's the thing even though escape
tonight is like the bizarre love child
of survivor and American Horror Story
where people get voted out and instead
of torches getting snuffed out by a
smarmy host it's your life getting
snuffed out by a bloodthirsty harpy
there is
deeper lore present throughout this
entire thing this isn't just a
competition reality show there is a
massive story that spans all three
seasons of this thing a story that most
viewers heck even us contestants aren't
aware of because it's so well hidden
don't believe me here's a great example
see this arm from season one seems like
just any old creepy clue right wrong
notice the patterns on the arm which
matches up to our mentor Calliope zarm
tattoos from season three the two are
connected at the end of our season
Calliope dies and somehow her arm ends
up back at the haunted house the
youtubers explore in season one there
are tons of little details just like
this sprinkled throughout the show all
pointing to the larger series narrative
and as I've gone back through to rebuild
the series in time for the show's return
and the return of some of my dearly
departed friends something is now isn't
clear to me something that I suspected
during my season but that I now see
beyond a reasonable doubt
the host and show's creator popular
youtube vlogger joey graceffa is
actually the villain of his own series
even though he acts just like any other
contestant fighting whatever murderous
clowns are bloodthirsty robots the show
throws your way that week he's one of
them working against us he's a plant a
villain someone out to sabotage his
friends and the craziest part of all is
that he might not even recognize it
beware my friends going forward the t
gets hot the plot lines start getting a
little bit spoilery so consider yourself
warned to understand the plot of the
series and the role joey plays and
bringing about the deaths of dozens of
popular online personalities
[Music]
we need to know where things began
season 1 opens with Joey explaining that
he's having weird dreams when he
suddenly inherits a large estate he
accepts it on blind faith and as if he
hasn't seen the plot of any horror movie
in existence ever crumbly decides to
move in he claims won't let me sleep
until I invite her in instead of being
like oh that's a red flag maybe I should
consider posting up at the Comfort Inn
instead he thinks that his insomnia will
be cured if he throws a party all of
this is very logical decision making
from Joey moving into the meet of
episode 1 it's revealed that the king of
conspiracy theories himself Shane Dawson
has been poisoned to dinner and dies
whoopsy
there goes Shane's next docu-series darn
it and I had already pre-ordered my
conspiracy theory makeup palettes they
come to learn that Shane was actually a
member of a secret society creatively
named the Society against evil which is
get this a society that fights against
evil truth in advertising for the win
the house that Joey's inherited is
possessed by an evil spirit and the gang
has to find a bunch of hidden artifacts
bring them all together and free
themselves with a ritual the society
against evil has marked clues around the
house album and season one progresses as
contestants get bumped off and Joey gets
closer and closer to his fully ghost
busted dream home the problem is Joey
doesn't exactly show himself to be on
the good guys side as the season goes on
we see Joey playing along as though he's
helping to rid the house of demons but
if you actually stop and look at his
behavior things just don't add up take
for instance this scene where Joey and
Lele pons uncover a Death Note which
gives them the opportunity to kill off
one of their friends by writing down
their name Lily suggests that they give
the decision up to fate by playing spin
the bottle
Joey however insists that they write
down glozell not only one of the most
popular players in the house but also
one of the most vocal and her suspicions
of Joey's role in all the murder that's
happening around us we buried Justine
but you were acting like you were just
so sad and I just don't believe that
you're really so sad why don't buy the
act Oh Joey
clothes Devils coming in at Joey
and now Joey's killed glozer why Joey's
rationale for making such a cruel choice
it was either her or me
Lili pretty much has to go along with
the decision is your house but if that
wasn't suspicious enough Joey then
proceeds to cover up his role in Gliese
Elle's murder I don't want them to know
that we put her name in the book making
up a lie and repeatedly pressuring Lili
about keeping the secret
see and is Joey sorry about his decision
does he regret killing off not only a
friend but also one of the most beloved
members of his party let him speak for
himself it's my party and I can kill
whoever I want to the two other people
who are suspicious of him but keep it
under wraps also happened to be the
final survivors of the season
so Joey invites his friends to a party
and then shows zero remorse as he kills
him off one at a time no big deal right
I mean it is but the goal is to escape
this house possessed by an evil spirit
so I guess it makes sense except again
there's one huge problem with Joey's
behavior Joey keeps the house at the end
of the season let me make that clear he
pockets the deed to a murder house
possessed by evil spirits an act that he
clearly knows is wrong because he
secretly does it outside of the sight of
the other surviving youtubers I mean
Joey I know la real estate is cutthroat
man I live here too but there's no
excuse for holding onto a property
that's literally killed eight of your
BFFs think anyone
well understand what happened tonight at
this house that's right Joey they won't
they think that you heroically escaped
with your life but what really happened
is that you racked up a death toll of
eight in exchange for some real estate
straight out of the shining even the
other survivors aren't fool we asked
some back for his next dinner party in
season two their response says it all
so another policy by Joey not today by
season two we see that the evil that's
possessed the house is now creeping into
Joey himself you can even see it start
to show up on his face at no point to
see you know asked for help or told
anyone like hey guys Joey here I think I
might have the touch of the curse going
on that would be a kick by YouTube video
Joey but do you do it nope over the
course of the season the next crop of
dead men and women walking worked their
way through a Victorian masquerade where
they fend off everything from the king
of vampires to an evil gingerbread woman
along the way we yet again see Joey
betraying the very people who are there
trying to help him out when DeStorm
calls Joey's team weak he always seems
weak slow can't keep up with us Joey
immediately responds by cutting his
throat
and Joey's wrath isn't just limited to
people who question him he even
sacrifices people from his own alliances
in Episode one Joey and Liza Koshi are
chained to sacrificial crosses destined
to be food for vampires they escape and
from that moment on they are practically
inseparable as you can imagine almost
becoming an undead buffet has a way of
uniting people until of course Joey
decides to turn on Liza I feel like
lives I could handle it what is this
about
Joey and I had a great time being a
great team and now he wants to send me
to my death
unfortunately the remaining players are
just so happy to be alive that they
don't call him out on it
so Joey slips by until the next episode
here finally Joey has to actually fight
for his own life after being unanimously
nominated by his team the only two that
haven't proven themselves yet are Joey
and Andrea after completing the
challenge for the second time in this
series Joey has to choose someone
outside of the challenge to die and
after about ten seconds of being
distraught about it he chooses Tana mojo
and then he's mad that he didn't get
himself a power gem in return it makes
me so angry that Tana just died and we
didn't get what we were promised geez
she hasn't even put on Tanic on yet joey
graceffa literally cancels Tana before
the internet does girl's been canceled
more times than Futurama by the end of
the season Joey has the blood of yet
another seven youtubers on his hands but
in an interesting twist he himself dies
in the final moments
unfortunately what his dead may never
die because joy is back at it in season
3 after making a quick pact with none
other than the Society against evil
which more I researched the more it
seems like their name might be
compensating for something at this point
it's unclear what side they're actually
on but what is clear is that they
offered Joey a choice he can get his
life back but to do so he'll have to
sacrifice the lives of yet another batch
of content creators joey graceffa ladies
and gentlemen taking down youtubers
faster than a mr. beast paintball
tournament and out this deal in which he
has to trade the lives of others for his
own life is of course a deal that Joey
accepts without question if they find
out my secret I'm ruined this time I'm
caught in the crossfire and we were off
to the carnival a carnival from the
1970s to be exact this
I'm Joey does actually bother to warn
everyone that they're headed into a
dangerous mission but you know dangerous
is a far cry from certain death Here I
am thinking that I'm finally cool enough
to be invited to a youtuber party but
instead of collabs I get kill abs they
kill me I die in fact Colleen and I both
died directly at Joey's hands in a
pretty suspicious way after we both call
him out for you know sacrificing all his
friends so that he and he alone can come
back to life you need me
liar anything you say seems to be a
trend across these three seasons huh you
see for the first time in the series we
all started to figure out that something
was going on and we decided to call Joey
out on it his Joey on our side or is he
just trying to kill us and for the first
time in the entire series Joey comes
clean about the fact that his life
depends on surviving the season I know
what was going on and I'm in a contract
that I would save this town and they
would bring me back to life if I don't
save this town I die with it and yeah he
brings out his little crocodile tears
but the fact of the matter is Joey if
you sentenced everyone around you to die
to make your little behind-the-scenes
deal I don't know how you guys would
take it pretty poorly actually cuz what
you just said
is that you're willing to trade nine
lives for yours Joey great there's no
justice here yeah you go dorky sheriff
matpat and then like clockwork anytime
anyone tries to disagree with Joey I end
up in the unfortunate position of dying
I fail in a nail-biting tiebreaker
against Manny
MUA by the way can we just take a second
to look at what a trihard I am here take
note reality TV contestants this is how
you get way to invest it into your
character anyway my ego and my life set
aside in the next episode there's an
even more blatant betrayal after Colleen
also calls into question the mighty
wisdom of Joey nice acting Joey I don't
believe any of it he even had a single
tear I swear to god that was a spit tear
one of the biggest things I feel I've
done so far was have a gut feeling about
Joey and then finds herself on the wrong
end of his death hammer
I'm gonna vote for you Joey I'm sorry I
came for you earlier but you were lying
to us and then just to make sure that
none of his other secrets get out Joey
makes sure that Colleen ends up in an
iron maiden literally screaming and
crying so at this point in the series
it's pretty clear that Joey leaves a
path of heartless deaths in his wake and
that he's also been part of a larger
evil scheme to save himself at the
expense of basically every creator he
follows on Twitter or is it well all
this time it looks like Joey is the big
series bad guy of his own show episode
after episode season after season what
if I told you there's actually something
else going on here
that Joey isn't an evil mastermind that
maybe Joey isn't even acting on his own
accord that Joey Graceffa is evil but
he's an evil pawn under the control of
someone else in his own show
sure in season 1 he invites a bunch of
friends to a deadly dinner party but we
already know he was compelled to do that
by a deep-seated evil that was working
inside the house and although he may
have defeated the curse that was holding
everyone inside the house the bigger
evil existed in the deed that he held on
to there was something else there the
whole time something much bigger and
much more dangerous than Joey in the
next go-around the show sets it up that
Joey and the gang are facing off against
the evil sorceress the big bad guy of
the season but if you actually pay
attention in episode 3 we get a glimpse
at the sorceress his backstory and it
tells us that we actually have much
bigger things to be afraid of than just
her the sorceress was once a peasant
girl who made a deal with a cursed God
for pound
she was once just a regular person but
then she made a deal with a cursed God
who looks a little like a Cthulhu
Squidward for power so when Joey says in
episode 1 this time I had no part in
inviting my friends someone set me up
he's being manipulated by the evil
forces of the cursed God Joey oh yeah
some of his decisions have been a little
questionable is just a player in a much
larger evil game we get confirmation of
this in episode 2 where we learned that
the baddie of this season needs the evil
that Joey carries in order to serve this
higher cursed God the spell requires the
evil Joey the spell requires the evil
Joey Carey
Oh Joey's name is randomly in the book
so we don't really know if he's hiding
something or or what's happening with
the journal again Joey is just the low
man on the evil totem pole and this
cursed God business isn't just a one-off
thing for the season it's clearly part
of the established overarching lore for
the entire series
fast forward to season three and the
cursed God comes up yet again this time
as the boss to the big baddie of that
season the carnival master in episode 1
Colleen discovers a diary which contains
our first and clearest mention of the
Carnival Masters intention the corrupted
artifacts have given the power I needed
to conform the people of this town to
vessels of being consumed everything
he's doing to the town of ever Locke is
all in service to some greater being the
same cursed God that possessed the
sorceress back in season 2 oh and I of
course missed all this deep lore going
down during season 3 because at the same
time this was going on I was busy
digging straight into a toilet full of
turd the clues have been inside things
maybe I need to start like squeezing the
turds I feel like that's some kind of
really apt metaphor for my life in
general but we won't dwell on that the
end of season 3 features one of the
team's mentors Mortimer suddenly turning
on us in service of the carnival master
he just like Joey throughout the series
has been manipulated by the overarching
evil forces at work in this universe and
serves as yet another example of an
otherwise decent person who's been used
as a pawn by the cursed God nothing sums
this up better than the carnival master
himself at the end of season 3 where he
explicitly says to Joey they caught you
in - that's not sure meaning that at
their best the society against evil is
not super helpful yet their worst there
maybe kind of the bad guys - and all of
us are caught in the middle
so yeah Joey might be acting out of his
own best interests and at the expense of
others but he never wanted to be a part
of this in the first place there's a
much bigger picture here from the looks
of things Joey's on a rocket to
Redemption in all-star season for trying
to redeem himself from what he's gotten
caught up into in the last three seasons
I had such good friends what I want more
than anything at this point is a way to
make all the wrongs I did bring and who
knows maybe the big bad of this season
will be the cursed God himself time to
put a stop to the evil where it all
began
so T LD w je definitely not the good guy
of escape tonight but he's just a pawn
in a much bigger game will he become a
hero this season will he be able to save
all the other youtubers and their future
adsense revenue I guess the only way to
find out is see where this next season
goes but hey that's just a theory ah
film theory more accurately a youtube
original theory and cut and hey I had a
blast being a part of escape tonight
season 3 I made some of my best on and
off YouTube friends through the
connections that I made on that show
when I said that this show is like the
biggest youtuber collab I wasn't kidding
so if you want to check out the new
season a lot of my friends are returning
for the all-star season coming up I may
even make an appearance or two in there
you never know keep an eye out so you
can binge through all the other seasons
on YouTube Premium right now go out
there check out my appearances see me
die see me come back to life and see me
ultimately win it all and then that way
you're caught up for the new season
that's going on this summer so go for it
you know that I'm gonna be watching
every new episode to cheer my friends on
and heck make sure that I was proven
right cuz I'm pretty sure about this one
Joey man can't trust him as far as I can
throw him based on that strong man
competition in season 3 it's obvious
that I cannot throw things very far
[Music]